[تصفيق]
مرحبا جميعا نزار قباني في احد قصائده
يقول ابحث عن مدينه نكتب ما شئنا على
جدرانها تدهشنا تقلقنا تخضنا مدينه لا
تقمع الحب ولا الشعر ولا تجمعنا مدينه
سماءها مفتوحه كدفتر الكتابه
كانت الساعه 10:30 بالليل كنت جالسه اني
واختي وكنا نتفرج مسلسل اوروبي وتحديدا
كان مسلسل اسباني وكان يحاكي فتره ما بين
القرن السابع عشر والقرن الثامن عشر يعني
فتره قديمه وكان في مشهد زفاف ملكي ناس
لابسين مواليد طويله فساتين طويله بوريك
وكان في حماه اسبانيه تكلم مرت ابنه اللي
هي العروس
التفتت لاختي قبل ما تلتفت المشهد كان
حرفيا مضحك لانه على اساس يحاكي ناس من
200 300 سنه وعلى اساس انهم نساء من
النخبه الحاكمه لكن يعني نفس الحوار دائما
ما يتغيرش ما بين الحمى
المهم التفتت لاختي تقول لي والله كيد
الحموات ما طلعش بس عندنا كمان عندهم ومن
زمان رديت عليها وقلت تخيلي هذا المشهد
عندنا في عدن بس اقلبيه على قديم
جاوبت عبارتي بسؤال قالت الا بصحيح ايش
كانوا يلبسوا عندنا العرائس في عدن قبل
100 سنه واكثر طبعا كان السؤال بلا اجابه
لانه فعليا ما طلعتش اي صوره دهنيه في
راسي ولان اختي ما كانتش متوقعه اي اجابه
كملت تفرقه المسلسل عادي بس عندي وقف
السؤال صراحه
وتخيلت لو انه هذا المنتج او المخرج
الاجنبي اجل عندنا وطلب انه ينتج فتره
يعني فيلم يحاكي فتره زمنيه قديمه في عدن
وطلب مننا بما انه نحن من سكان المدينه
معلومات زي ايش كانوا يلبسوا الناس في ذيك
الفتره ايش نوعيه الاحاديث اللي كانت
تشغلهم شكل الاثاث اللي كانوا يستخدموه
يعني طقوس اعراسهم جنازاتهم وغيره من هذه
التفاصيل اللي طبيعي اي منتج عشان يخرج
فيلم حقيقي يعبر عن حياه الناس في هذاك
العصر طبيعي انه يطلبه فكرت يا ترى ايش من
مدونات توثيقات كتبت في ذيك الفتره تقدر
تعطينا وتعطيه صوره واضحه عن حياه الناس
الموضوع فعلا السرعه انتباهي لاني لما
حاولت اوصل لمعلومات تعطيني عن حياه الناس
قديما لقيت الموضوع اصعب مما تصورته واللي
صدمني اكثر اني حتى لقيت صعوبه في اني
اوصل لحياه الناس اللي عاشوا في بدايات
القرن العشرين يعني نتكلم عن قرن فائد
اقتباس او استشهاد سريع اذا كنا في
التوثيق السياسي ما زلنا احيانا نلجا
للخارج عشان يعطونه وثائق تتكلم عن ماضينا
احيانا فايش ممكن تتصوري انهم يعني ممكن
يكون وثقوا تفاصيلهم قديما طبعا هذا كان
رد احد ابرز الموثقين والباحثين في
المدينه لما سالته كم موثقه لنا الاولون
تفاصيل حياتهم المجتمعيه
كان في حاجه او جانب مضيء بالموضوع هو انه
عرفني على نوع من العلم قد يكون نوعا ما
صعوبه للبعض بس جدا معناه لطيف علم
الانثروبولوجي علم الانثروبولوجي كده
ببساطه وبدون اي تعقيد هو علم الانسان
يختص حرفيا بكل ما يخص الانسان من
معتقداته وافكاره حتى شكل الاثاث اللي
يستخدمه شكل اللباس طقوس افراحه احزانه
حتى حكاياته واساطير وهو على فكره حاجه
مختلفه عن التوثيق السياسي اللي نحن
تعودنا عليه يعني التوثيق السياسي احيانا
على رغم اهميته الا انه ما يعطيش الصوره
الكامله لثقافه بلد او مدينه او جماعه
حلاوه التوثيق الانثروبولوجي انه متى ما
تم توثيق هذه التفاصيل الانثروبولوجيه
فيها ان تحفظ الثقافه لقرون حيه حتى بعد
موت اصحابه عشان كذا الدراما السينما
الاعمال الفنيه والاعمال الادبيه دائما ما
تتفاعل مع نوعيه كذا معلومات لانه متى ما
تم توثيق هذه التفاصيل لاشخاص ان شاء الله
يكونوا عاشوا قبل الف سنه انا قادر بعمل
فني واحد بفين بمسلسل قادر استحضرهم من
جديد وكانهم عايشين بيننا الان
اتخيل احيانا لو كان الاولين ورثوا لنا
حياتهم موثقه ابسط انواع التوثيقات كنا
قدرنا نقنع الاجيال الحاليه انه اللي كان
في عدن قديما من تعايش من اختلاف من
انفتاح من تنوع كان حقيقي ما كانش مجرد
وهم وحواديت وقيل وقال يعني تخيلوا معي
مثلا لو كان وثقوا لنا تفاصيل التعايش
اللي كانت حاصله من الاديان الطوائف
العرقيات اللي كانت موجوده يعني وثقوا لنا
مثلا تفاصيل زي قصص تعاملاتهم اليوميه
حوادثهم حتى مشاكلهم ايام اعيادهم
المختلفه كيف كانوا يقضوها
طبيعه الهتاف اللي كان يردد مواقع الملاعب
وغيره من هذه التفاصيل كم ممكن الرجوع
لهذه المواقع واحياها بالرياضات من جديد
حتى الحكايه والاساطير لو كانوا وثقوها
لنا بقلم اهل الي عثروها وشعور الخوف
والغموض اللي شعروها في هذاك الوقت كان
ممكن يكون عندنا الان ماده غنيه لقصص
افلام سينمائيه نشارك فيها بالمهرجانات
زيت مطيع
لما وثق في روايته اسطوره طهش الحوبان قدر
يحفظها للاجيال من النسيان وقدرت توصلنا
الان كمان يعني اسطوره جنيه العقبه على
فكره ما تقلش ابدا من اسطوره النداهه في
مصر كل الفرق انه نداهه مصر توثقت وانعمل
عليها
فيلميات العقبه ما توثقتش حتى الاماكن
والمباني اثريه دينيه ايا كان لو كانوا
مكتفوش بتوثيق العناوين واتقوا لنا
الاحداث اللي حصلت المواقف والرجال اللي
عثروها الاهميه اللي كانت عليها وشربت هذه
المعلومات لطلاب مدرسه حتى يزوروها في
السنه في رحلاته المدرسيه مر كل عام هل
ممكن كانت هذه الاجيال ان تسمح فيما بعد
انه مثلا ينهد معبد ديني عمره اكثر من قرن
ونصف عشان ينبني عليه مبنى تجاري او
صهاريك عمره اكثر من الاف السنين عشان
ينبني عليها عماره كم دور ما يتجاوزش
عمرها شهور
هذه التفاصيل على قدر بساطته هي من تحفظ
ثقافات الامم والبلدان والمدن هي من تحفظ
ذاكره اهل المدن من النسيان
اعتمادا كل مره على الذاكره الشفويه
والسماعيه هو اعتماد مؤقت يميتنا عبر
الزمن لانه يموت ويذهب بذهاب اصحابه خليها
في بالكم دائما اسهل الطرق لتجريف مدنيه
المدن واطفاء انواره هو تفريغ من التفاصيل
قاعد ضعيفه متلاشيه مع الزمن اما هذه
التفاصيل على الجانب الاخر لما توثق تدون
تقرا تعرف تتناقل الاجيال قير عن قيل هي
من تخلق هويه قويه صامده من التجريف عبر
الزمن هي من تخلق هويه قادره على احتضان
الجميع دون تمييز
لمدن اكثر تعايش وسلام لانه هويات المدن
الحقيقيه عمري ما تسال ساكنيها عن اصولهم
مناطقهم بقدر ما تحتضن من يذوب في مدنيته
ويسهم في سلامه وبنائه
اني لا ادعي هنا يعني في اللحظه اللي
جمعتنا الان لا ادعيني هذيك المؤرخه
الكبيره او الباحثه المخضرمه المساله يعني
ابتدات بمجرد تساؤلات عفويه وحتى اشير هنا
انه التوثيق مش لازم فكرته انه ترتبط مثلا
بالدراسات والبحوث الاكاديميه وان الشخص
لازم يكون باحث ومتخصص لا ممكن يكون
التوثيق عبر لك اشخاص عاديين على فكره
معظم الدراسات اللي تكون تبتدا بمذكرات
احيانا او توثيقه اشخاص عاديين وبعدين
ممكن المحللين والباحثين يبنوا عليها كتب
ودراسات التوثيق عشان كذا ممكن يكون عبرنا
كعديين وباسهل الطرق كلا في مكانه ودوره
واتجاهه مثلا من الطرق السهله مذكرات
شخصيه كتبت باسلوب سهل
وتنحفظ نحفظ فيها معايشاتنا اليوميه
تفاصيل مجتمعنا او مثلا تدوينات الكترونيه
نوثقه دائما كل فتره ونرشفه على ورق صوره
يرافقه شرح وتاريخ نستخرج كل فتره مع
الزمن وحطي في البوم
المهم والجديد نتعلم كيف يعني نوثق بالشكل
الطويل وش التوثيق المؤقت اللي تعودنا
عليه تبع يلا كراكيب وصوره عتيقه واوراق
عتيقه ويلا نرمي لا دائما نحط في بالنا
التوثيق لنا والاجيال يجوا بعدنا عشان على
الاقل اذا ما قدرناش نحول هذه التوثيقات
الى كتب تتكلم عننا الاجيال اللي بعدنا
تلاقي ماده تتكلم عننا
يوم نصحى على مدن ما نعرفهاش ما تشبهناش
مدن بلا طعام بلا لون بلا رائحه واحيانا
اتساءل انه ليش دائما نستنى الاخرين هم من
يؤرخوا عنهم هم اللي يذكرونا بالصوره اللي
هم حابينه مش بالصوره اللي حابين نطلع
فيها
دائما نقول يعني احيانا يا الله يا الله
لما الاخرين وثقوا عنك تسرق اغانينا تخرب
اثارنا تزور اصل اكلاتنا نحن عادي عادي
كانه تعودنا الجلوس على رف الهامش
والمتفرج بعدين ليش دائما نقلل ما قيمه
التفاصيلنا وننظر له بالنظر القليله وننسى
انه التفاصيل هي نحن ونحن هي التفاصيل
وانهم متى ما قللنا من قيمه تفاصيلنا
قللنا من قدر انفسنا امل دنقل يقول الشاعر
هي اشياء لا تشترى دائما
[تصفيق]
نخلي في بالنا ان التوثيق وسيله لديمومتنا
وبقائنا وسيله لكتابه قصتنا اللي تخصنا
نحنا واللي تحجز لنا مساحه حضاريه زينا زي
الاخرين
وان التوثيق دائما ببقينا على طول وعشان
بعد كم سنه ما يوقفش حدا نفس هذا الوقفه
ويسال نفس السؤال اللي سالناه اليوم لماذا
غابت عنا التفاصيل شكرا
[تصفيق]